speaking of people that's gonna make  your lap I was just with Tiffany Haddish  who makes me he at the New York premiere  of her upcoming comedy nobody tool and  it is clear this tip is at the top of  her game movies this year is this for  you I think it'll be a total of eight  movies this year levy seven she ready  she worked it tiffany plays a woman who  was released from prison and reunites  with her sister tika Sumpter and their  mother will be Goldberg this connection  is so reckoning hello what mama you and  a window the movie was written and  directed by Tyler Perry who will soon be  celebrating a major milestone I'll be 15  next year it has been 25 years how old  must have my life he's been in this  business Tyler called the shots on set  but it was Whoopi who directed the  purple carpet cast photo keV I didn't  just laugh  I screamed during this movie nobody's  will hit theaters on Friday go see it  twice  [Music]